Hey! How it's goin'.
Damn, I'm excited today. One my favorite games this year, Little Nightmares, just came out with a DLC.
I think it's this one.
Oh, God. I hope it's that one.
I don't know, it came out of nowhere. It's early - the DLC is early. I repeat everyone.
ohhhhh
Such a nice surprise. This is definitely it. What? Who are you?
Wow, why does your head look like a meatball. You look delicious.
How did we end up here? Oh, I'm drowning. Uh-oh.
Oh, we're at - that's - I remember this place
This is where we met the enemy for the first time.
Oh, I'm so cute!
So then - we're on the boat still then.
We're playing as one of the ~*children*~
This is awesome. I'm so glad we're getting more content of this game!
Where do I go ?
I forgot, I forgot about Teddy. Can I go back and get him? I forgot the controls. I've got everything come on. Okay great
Jeez is he gonna come and check on me. I best be going then
Alright well this way it is there he is oh. He's he chasing the girl
From the original that's funny. Oh
No, she died
I had this theory that this guy is a nice guy he just looks horrible
Cause he never he never actually kills you he just captures you or whatever maybe just one of those clingy parents, you know
Actually, you know you know what I'll take it back. He's horrible there you go. It's the boat
Whoop !
luckily placed
Mattress we've been here as well.
Oh Shit, it's the slug. I know what those do
I will not say hi to you today mister
Giant black
Don't say penis, okay, cool
We've been there as well. This is weird. It's like we're playing behind the scenes
ah there is a little Girl down there
????
All right, we'll tip tap our way through
If I remember how I grabbed stuff I need, no I need to jump down here
okay, I see
I complete.. I don't know which one I grab with and I know it's just such an important move
Here we go
We're gonna have to run back aren't we?
I have to remember which one I run on
That's sneak you know, let... sorry
Okay, Sprint, grab
flashlight, crouch, okay
Sorry now you don't have to hear me?
Keep going, I don't know the controls
C'mon buddy there you go. Oh, God where do I hide here ?
What a major fuckup !
I thought for sure that would be covered in the middle. I just assumed that there would be. Great let's do that again
What the fuck was that. All right here we go
I don't trust that bitch tho
I ain't trusting no bitches that be snitchin like snitches here we go come back here girl
Where you going girl with three bag? I'm going to throw up cube into your fucking face come here
You want this Cube?
You want to play Minecraft
This game is just like my real life come back here lady. Where'd you go?
I love this area. It's so cute
Alright. I assume. We have to go back up here. There's no potato people left
I don't know why I'm doing this it's figured
great job Felix! end your life, Jesus Christ
Okay, I can just go here. It's fine. It's fine. I know what I'm doing
Professional gamer here look I have toilet paper. That's right. That's right. Thank you everyone toilet paper
Anyone need some I got you fam. What is she doing?
Oh what a dick.. that's fine. I have toilet papers
Yeah, yeah
See I got you fam coming to get you girl. I don't know why I'm coming to get you
But I'm gonna catch up that I was a joke everyone. Thank you. 10/10 all right let's grab this
And let's go down nice, and easy. Where's she going?
She's going in there in the hole. She's going in the hole come back here when it's safe to jump off now
I would assume. I'm fine. I'm fine
It'd be funny if you started playing as the inside character, or some shit all of a sudden. Plot twist
This game is Canon
Okay, I assume we have to go down there, but I also kind of want to check around
Okay, well let's just go
Whoop ! haha
WHOOOOOOOOOOOOOA!!!!!!!!!!
I'm fine
Swim Swim Swim Swim swim I don't trust it, I don't trust the water. I don't trust the water
I just don't trust the water get out of the water. Thank you. What the fuck
What do I do here?
Oh hell no, it's vibrating my controller is like non-stop
Vibration alright, we got it. We got to pull this
Which I don't like even more
Why is my controller freaking out?
it's like *Imitates vibration*
Jezz do you see it's my Scrotum. Look at it I'm vibrating like crazy
What is happening?
What is... Oh okay here we go?
I did it everyone let's just go through I don't want to check the background
Ah we get the flashlight, now we can use it
Cool which you use with B
nice
Nice, and cozy. Are you scared now? I bet you're scared. I never get scared so it's okay. Oh God. That's a giant slug thing
all right, I would say hi, but
I gonna go with "bye" this time thank you
Ok here we go yes, the we're going great
so far ZERO DEATH (2 deaths) Oh shit Jesus
fucking Christ you distracted me nearly got me killed boy.
"Crouch" Yes, ah shi-
Nope coming from the ceiling not a problem. I saw that one. NO I got stuck in the pipe
What the fuck ah?
It keeps vibrating. Oh now it stops. I thank God that was super annoying
Fucking hell. I got stuck in this stupid pipe
Jesus Christ they're faster in the water
It's almost like they're water creatures or something
Hey look at that. Yeah,  oh, God. What do I do here? Oh?
Yeah, boy. hell yeah mate that was fucking awesome man alright, so
Aren't you gonna like?
There you go, okay, whoa
Oh God that does not sound nice. HA yeah
I did it zero death everyone (3 deaths) Thank you so much. Oh God, okay
The fuck is this ?
Oh God, I don't trust anything
Whoop oh God swim swim swim swim swim swim.....
What's happening here? What is this
okay,
I don't know what this DLC is called I don't know what it's about. I just
Just randomly saw it was available and then I'm like hell. Yeah. I'm just gonna get it
Oh God, okay. This is very dark. Give me my flashlight. I don't think I can
AHHHH
Piece of potato pie hell yeah
Legit he looks like a meatball
Panera is your home Ikea is my city
Whoa that was deeper than I expected
I strongly feel like some sort of yep
Okay, well this is great. This is where we die. There's chairs. There's chairs coming to kill me
Please for the love of God Swim
Girl you almost got me Mr.Chair not today
This meatball lives another day, bow. I said bow instead of bro. Thank you
Uncut footage you know it always does well
Doesn't show how cringy I am in as a human being thank you. Thank you everyone.
I don't know why I did that right there a giant rectum here
I don't like it
Where am I supposed to go here?
No click it. I don't know
Down here, maybe I feel like I would die
No, I'm fine with that
How about that?
Excellent. What is this?
Alright, you come up with me now. Oh God that looks that looks very bad, uh excuse me
AH
Ah, that did the trick great excellent. Let's let's go here.
Oh God, they're really fucking fast
AHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH!!!!!!!!!!!NO!!AHHHHHHHHH
Why didn't I run I forgot I could I pressed A I'm so stupid Jesus, okay?
i'll try to run this time that would be I would be super Super Duper
I don't know why I feel safer on this thing, but really in reality. I'm fucking not
Hey look at that if you actually run you win. How about that? Who would have thought you should have to run crazy
I don't trust it
no
Oh God it's speaking to me. Come out and play pewdie.
Okay, great
More water for Fuck's sake man
Looks like we got a lot of climbing to do here bros a lot of climbing for one meatball to make
What part of the ship is this who places a random toilet there?
No toilet paper for you, buddy. hehe, oh God grab it
There you go
video game rules if there's a switch you gotta what the fuck ah
fuck
Alright fine. Maybe we need to release the pressure first if you know what I mean
Alright, here we go
There you go
hey, how about that
Wow, what a tricky puzzle there, oh mah gawd x3, my ass is filling up
Yeah, yeah
Yeah, oh, I get it. I get it we gotta hurry up
whoo
Swim Swim Swim Swim Swim Swim Swim Swim Swim Swim Swim
How do I, I died I died everyone I died
Did I not...What?
Yeah, that's how drowning works everyone in case you weren't aware
You lose any breath of air. You instantly die?
There you go
lil' Above my water hey there that  does the trick
Stop stop. That's enough. Ahh Sewage. Thank you wow try not to get it in your mouth, buddy
There you go nice
nice and Smooth
Man I love playing this game
It plays so nicely I love it
There's something about it
All right new place
Let's save this barrel for no reason no, I can't
Okay, well, I don't fucking know push you out. No just look at it
What about here, oh okay. Wow... hahahaha
Oh jeez. can I pull you no it's definitely something in the water here
You can feel it
I literally can feel it my my, Oh, God. I see him my controller is vib.... Well, what the fuck it's a giant's wow that's creepy
Don't kill me Mr.Sea Monster get up UPPP!!!
THE FUCK!!
Get up get up no it doesn't work swim leave me alone
Ah GET UP
I hate this
Get up get up get up......Edgar is freaking out
oh
God, I'm sweating for real. Oh
My God sweating for real. I am not a fucking seal
Ah Jeez
Okay, calm down
We can do this easy easy game boom bam slam...
Sam and  damn don't fucking touch me
The Forbid can't touch it ah fuck you
What you gonna do huh?
I'm going here for no reason hey, you like alcohol. I got you fam that got grabbed it
What is this?
Saw one of these before okay, so these are the new collectibles
Okay, great. It's a bottle post
Great. Hey, maybe we can use it as distraction
Idiot idiot
Yes
Boi, that was straight up BS
Oh it's bs, no it's bz
I know kids slang shut up great jump there Felix you
Gold Star Buddy
I see you oh God.
ASSHOLE
You're a real penis
Don't fucking touch me man
Through the box now, okay, I see how it is
Oh my God this thing I hate it now you gonna get mad at me. Oh he's not playing the game perfectly hell
Yeah, if I did it he I'd be over a long time ago, man
Bitch, you can't fucking touch me
Swim Swim Swim get up ain't that fucking hard bitch
Fuck a duck. That's right. Bye. Bye
Bye
Here we go can we pull this it's a box everyone. I can climb here. I see it now, okay
Sorry, I wasn't paying attention
That is probably
your mama
Your mama everyone your mama jokes, Top of the morning now that too much ain't it unless it goes down by itself
No it doesn't
Alright that will do little dead copes that'll do what the fuck
Oh my God, okay, well then die, then fucking die
Why does he not grab that what's your fucking problem alright? I'm ready for you. Don't fucking fuck with me alright cuz I will
Swing back swing back slowly, but that was not nearly good enough. Oh
Now you can grab it. Oh, that's interesting
That's really interesting
thanks for letting me know about that one
You want some fish come to get it ? Oh, there's more of it
It just keeps coming looks Delish
I'll have some
Yeah, take some have some have some more  while I swim. It's way tastier than me look. I'm skinny that
Fish is fat like your mama gottem absolutely just get up. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you
Fuck are you man?
Got him and got him right am I right hey, you want a shoe you want a fucking shoe. Hey
I know you want a shoe you want you want a shoe here you go, err. It's a fish
bitch
absolutely rekt no recovery
Now there's more shoes could do it all day, but you know what I'm not gonna. I have dignity oh, God
What am I oh ah ah
I didn't mean for that to happen
Alright, how do I get up there get up here? No that's not what I
Hey, I could do push up
What else do we got a ball. We got a ball everyone
Dribble going left going right going he doesn't double spin he goes up
And he shoot it, fuck!
Stop I don't want you Mr.Can. Stop can
Thank you
Alright here we go, here we go just aim at the thing and shoot
Okay, let's try that again
Aim at the basket and shoot the fucking ball
Yeah
Hell yeah, man. hell yeah, man. What
does that do then? I don't know why I just did this
What the fuck
Are you telling me that
All I had to do was climb up here
Is that no I can yeah? Oh what?
Fucking distracted by a basketball game Jesus Christ
Well done, well done Felix
Okay, here we go. It's Gonna be an epic jump,
Hell yeah men. I did it man. Hell yeah man I can't reach the
Ah fuck I can all it's fine who needs them oh
I see it wow that's cool. That's actually pretty cool
Nope, okay
Here we go. Can you run in a straight line, please Mister meatball fuck you meatball
Yes, oh, no
get up get up get a fuckin a
why am I singing in this shit man ah chair you're
Not even doing it for me man
Alright I get it. I need to push the chair
Mr.. Chair is my best... I can't push chair. So fuck it then
Maybe I can just climb these handles okay. I can nope that's not what I wanted you to do, but you know
Live your life the way you want to live it
Rule one there's the lever you gotta pull it. Oh, wow that's a lot deeper than I thought
That's what she said, okay. I'll stop I promise
Like you've never made that joke okay. Sorry. I didn't know I had a connoisseur. ew trypophobia what the fuck
Okay, they really don't want that pot to break clearly so we're gonna fucking smash the shit out of it
Something living is inside. I'm going to get the rat
Type in the comments right now what you guess it is inside, the pot. I know it's going to be a key
But what else all right? I'm dorothy exploring you guys right now. Come on. Tell me push. It bye. Bye
It was a slug
Congrats to everyone that gets the slug
Probably no one because I am the smartest and I'm always right, so the rat is actually the right answer. I think
If you mean, Mr.. Slug could you get the fuck out of my way please?
All right, all right. Yep. Look how he walks by sucking what a shitty life
grab the key yes, and then run
excellent
and then no, that's not what I
Yes, that's how you unlock doors Felix. All right now. It's time to get that fuck out of here. Bye. Bye. Bye.
Hell yeah man
Doing great zero deaths by the way really proud of this playthrough doing really well haven't died a single time
Okay, here we go another area. What's up got electricity that he pressed the button make it stop,  yes, that's right
No, it's still electric
But now the current doesn't leave the water so we're safe we saf, but it could be time so let's be careful
Take me up, please
Up and onwards, this meatball really loves water, huh all right. Let's press the button again. See what happens
It's probably going to go up. We have plenty of fucking temperature fuck. I'm dead. I'm alive
Yes, that was not the way I imagined things to go, but it worked out
I mean of course perfectly calculated zero deaths s by the way hello bucket. You're coming with me
Never mind stay there then you potato son of a bitch see if I give a shit fucking fucking shit
We're back in the showers
Oh God, that's a sexy bitch. We saw her face and shit. Oh, I get it now I get it
Why people like water no don't fucking no stop you need to stop
You're ugly all right. You need to stop everything you're doing, oh God
Oh my God look at that face. swim the fuck up. AHH!!
That's right. There will be no ass for you tonight boy. Oh, God grab that and don't fuck up
Have you seen that gif so I almost suggest that would have been embarrassing oh?
Of the little girl that gets pulled down by a seal in the water or an otter maybe it is
Fucking hilarious Google it. Google it right now
Oh, God. He's coming back right away. What the fuck?
Dude chill chill Brah chill chill chill alright, I'm telling you to chill
Chill out relax max. all cool. Shoot some ball outside a pool
Okay, here. We go. Let's go for it
When a couple of guys they were up in no good start to make a trip travel in my neighborhood
I got in one super little fight and my mother got like wow
Yes, those are the original lyrics oh God, I think she's piss now
We got momentum, baby
Hell yeah, let's keep going fucking killing it killing it man killing it for a living hell yeah man that was fucking off
Thank you Felix. I mean, thank you myself
See I have to compliment myself cuz you bros not fucking do it.  Look at these gaming skills, bro
Someone's like you don't believe that I play video games all day every day
Zero deaths deaths by the way
And we keep it that way son. That's right that's right motherfucker. You can go suck a dick without ugly face boy.
Hell yeah
Nailed it skills. Oh you thought I skills ah I'm dead. I'm dead. You know I get these skills by respecting wha..mon
Oh, there's a hole there
What's oh?
What?
Okay
the Epic Troll
Let Epic troll everyone got em and no toilet paper for you, son. That's right these as well
Okay, now maybe not maybe not. Whatever. I don't care. I don't care
whoop
that was fucking epic that was like a superhero spider-man jump right there, baby right there, baby alright. We're gonna have to pull this briefcase
Oh, God
no, I said pull it
I guess I can't do it, huh
Alright, whatever. I'm guessing. We have to transport an item from one side to another
while still managing the water
Easy game is easy zero deaths puzzle destroying bruh absolutely havoc, okay, press
All right, give me that little triangle piece of shit
I think I see it probably one of these mother truckers
No, that's an ugly ass
Where are you all right toilet paper toilet paper doesn't get wet
there it is okay, and
I have something to tell you bros. It's a little embarrassing oh, we saw before why didn't you tell me then
Oh God, I'm going to die now
No I'm fine. Okay my ass fallen asleep is what I'm trying to say
Good job, you did it wow amazing other way?
Okay perfect
Can I don't want nothing to do with you Cen
Wait, sorry I did it wrong
boi
genius genius
Oh no, and he's dancing like he dances with his bro
Yeah, I get it. Oh
That's right sneeze compilation fuck you not today. No not today
Okay, here we go
Boi, you're going right inside that little red
in case you didn't realize triangle. Goes in triangle. They painted it red for us how nice
How nice everyone
We're Gonna have to redo this
Now let's redo this
Shut up Edgar. No one likes you either
You are legit
can level of dog
if you were a
Kitchen household item you'd be a can Edgar. Okay. God damn it. I fucked that up didn't I
I forgot to press the button didn't. I'm a fu... why did no one tell me
I might have to strike off the genius on my title that was pretty fucking
I love me. I love you
Here we go okay ready you ready you ready boi. You're ready boy here we go man. Hey
Bitches say no that sounded weird, okay here we go. Yeah boi. We did it. We did it man
Easy this game is easy, man doors I'd be fucking them
What? oh shit, she's sitting in the chair and shit
The fuck was she doing
Oh God don't panic, don't panic. I'm sure I'm dead
That's fine. That's fine. Just swim
Just don't worry. Don't worry. I'm absolutely destroyed
hey, it's me. I'm back so basically there's not that much left I
So I thought okay. I might as well
Just finishes in one episode instead of dragging it out to two. I know I'm a nice person
Jesus fucking Christ calm down
Oh my God this bitch is not messing around is she
All right well I am a dead man now
Well, it looks like you don't have to do that shit
Can she mess with it?
Oh my God you asshole go
Oh my Lord
God, she's mean I do not like her
Shit oh!!
OH!!!
How is it to watch? I'm like. Oh okay? I turn on the television you think bitches like television, huh?
It seemed like I would climb onto that lamp doesn't it. Oh thank God that worked
Okay, another lever you all know the oh God ah. Stop you're such a prick
Now what ah I meant to land on them
What's the plan here? Oh, I see, oh I'm dead
Get up get up get up NOO. What the fuck are you doing get up again
Bitch is coming up here now
Oh God, what do I do? There's the hole there stop it? Oh?
I got fried like potato pie
I can fucking push it, I try so many times to push it
Go down your stupid TV. Oh, that's right. You get fried bitch
You got fried like pizza pie motherfucker
motherfucker
Yes, I am the one
Hell God damn it bitch is Dead
That's right that's worth a high five. Are you ready?
Okay, alright. Fuck I ruin it
Okay, my flashlight still works after all that. That's great
Top of the morning to your ladies
This is Pewdiepie here. I stole jacksepticeye's brand now with these headphones
The fuck are you doing?
Something tells me this bitch is not dead
You know when you kill them you when you when you have something annoying for a long time
They never die okay you want them to die and then they die and then they never die alright
It's Friday the 13th all over again. Why am I speaking like a pillow?
Alright long ass ladder
It better be a sign that says you're awesome at the top of this
oh Jezz
Oh, that was the collecting guy fuck's sake
Maybe he maybe he told whispers you're awesome, dude. I love your shit man, oh shit
We're locked in here with a little girly no. No, aah
We were the one that had to go. What did he do with us
My mind is thinking some pretty
sick stuff right now
disgusting despicable
I believe that was the little nightmares Dlc short, but sweet as you say I liked it very
Nice, I don't think it compared to
The original one but I'll take whatever we can get I thought it was great anyway
I love this
cinematic
Platforming type of genre. I really hope they make more of them. I hope this games does well, so more people will follow
I wasn't sure if inside did well, or not
I understand it's a it's
Not maybe just about justifiable for a lot of people to pay the amount when you get a shorter
Amount of gameplay out of it, but I think it's cool that they make DlC like this, so you get a little bit extra
Let me know what you thought of the DLC any thoughts. Maybe something. I missed they would like to be enjoyed watching and as always
Sister fister